to store my house with a greater force
than was used to take down bin Laden or
El Chapo or Pablo Escobar to terrorize
my wife and my and my dogs is it's
unconscionable I would be more than
happy they knew I was represented and
they contacted my attorneys I would have
voluntarily turned myself in I would
have been able to wear a suit and tie
for my mug shot it would have looked a
lot better rods are always caring about
fashion if you read Rogers rules Roger
stone this morning blasting the
treatment he received from the FBI
heavily armed officers 27 of them 17
vehicles pre-dawn raid guns drawn on his
house amid lying to Congress the Muller
investigation meanwhile stone is
expected to be arraigned tomorrow in DC
on seven counts including lying to
Congress joining us now with reaction
author of the book the myth of Russia
collusion the inside story of how Donald
Trump really one Republican strategist
Roger stone let's get it a pre-dawn raid
and all the people that we mentioned in
the last segment that we know lied to
Congress it doesn't happen to them
Hillary got a pass by a guy that
interviewed her that said she he wanted
her to win a hundred million a zero what
do you make that this only happens to
you manna fort and comb but none of
these other people that lie to Congress
and not saying that you did by the way
no Sean it's extraordinary Comey clapper
Brennan McCabe and Hillary themselves
all lied in their case they lied about
material consequential things to the
extent that I made errors of memory in
my four and a half hours of voluntary
testimony they're inconsequential this
is this indictment is thinner you can
watch CNN they'll tell you it's a slam
dunk my attorneys don't think so but I'm
targeted here because they want to
silence me I mean I'm 66 years old I
support the Second Amendment but I don't
own a firearm I don't have a valid
passport I'm not a flight risk that the
court gave me essentially released me on
bond on my signature
not a flight risk I can't swim even
though they had to and fibia units
pulled up to the canal behind my house
they completely surrounded my house
really get some weapons
I really can't assault weapons pointed
at my at my you know at my at my chest I
opened the door looking down the barrel
of two assault weapons I am wearing a
Roger stone did nothing wrong t-shirt
and a pair of gym shorts I'm barefooted
the handcuffed me walk me out the street
I'm concerned because my wife is
hearing-impaired she's virtually deaf
without her hearing aids she hadn't
awoken I was afraid that they would
think she wasn't complying with an order
and shooter you know and the idea that
they had to do this because they were
worried that I would tamper or destroy
evidence is absurd I've been under
investigation for two years why would I
wait till Thursday
by the way I've destroyed no evidence
whatsoever and I'm charged with
non-violent process crosses here we go
again
no conspiracy here exactly it raises a
lot of questions beyond the double
standard to raises questions about the
tactics but if we have a duel justice
system in this country say goodbye to
the country and I'm serious
this this should be nonpartisan that for
something like this if there's no Muller
investigation
there's no jeopardy at all for anybody
and then you have to think of what
George Ellis said are they putting the
screws to you
so you're singing or compose and say
what they want so that you don't spend
or risk spending the rest of your life
in prison well I think it a great - a
great deal this is meant to silence me I
mean my radio show at infowars.com and
our program is heavily censored it's
very hard for me to get the opportunity
to defend myself
when I came out of the courthouse I was
being shouted down I couldn't even make
a statement this is a not only effort to
silence me because I support Donald
Trump and I've been a critic of the
Muller investigation and I think Donald
Trump is making America great again he's
my friend of 40 years I have great
affection for him and his
family I I'm not going to testify
against him because I possess no
negative information there is no Russian
collusion this is a witch on no it's a
everybody after the first WikiLeaks
thumb one that everybody trying to find
out was WikiLeaks has a history of never
being wrong whether you like them or not
they've never been wrong and the fact
everybody was speculating and with all
due respect in one of your emails that's
even mentioned in the indictment your
speculation that whatever's coming next
is about the Clinton Foundation you were
wrong which kind of proves that you were
fishing and digging and trying to find
out what might they have let's find out
what they have you did not steal
anything you did not conspire to steal
anything and the Pentagon Papers case my
reading of it is very clear by the way
the New York Times published WikiLeaks
has did all these other publications is
that as long as you don't conspire to
steal you can print you can go with
stole a material of somebody else
correct yeah yes they're trying to
criminalize legitimate political inquiry
they're trying to they're trying to
criminalize free speech which is really
what's this about this is about look I
honestly believe that they are going to
try to charge the President and the Vice
President with some hooked up frame of
Russian collusion that way they could
make Nancy Pelosi president she could
make Hillary Clinton vice president and
then step aside it's a nightmare but I
think that's what they have in mind
there is no Russian collusion
I had no collaboration with WikiLeaks
I'm not charged with conspiracy believe
me if they could have made that case
they would have but they want to silence
me because I will stand up for Donald
Trump that's what this is really about
you have been you proudly say you you
operate in political dark arts meaning
you also purposely try to mess with
people's heads because that a fair
characterization well Sean any honesty's
I got a tip a legitimate tip that told
me that the WikiLeaks disclosures were
significant and that they would come in
October i hyped that tip relentlessly to
drive voter attention and media
attention to the ultimate disclosures
because i was told they were a bombshell
that doesn't mean I knew what
that's called politics it's legal that's
wrong on one of them your mention of
Podesta you were talking specifically
about one Podesta were you not and no I
was actually talking correct no I was
talking about both Podesta brothers
because on July 31st Peter Schweitzer
wrote a devastating monograph called
from Russia with money about John and
Tony making millions from the oligarchs
around Putin in aluminum in a uranium in
gas in banking and then on the 14th of
August
Breitbart published another story by by
Schweitzer tying Tony Podesta to the
same Ukrainian political power T as does
Paul Manafort so I said the Podesta's
time in the barrel would come what I was
saying was I intended to get that
information on a background basis to a
number of reporters any other narrative
about what happened there is false and
there was no controversy about my tweet
for six weeks until it is alleged that
stone was foreshadowing Podesta's emails
being stolen let me be clear
I never knew the source or the content
of any allegedly hacked or allegedly
stolen emails that is a lie you know
Alan Dershowitz said it well and I think
that's evident and all of this 621 days
we're criminalizing political
differences we've got a dual justice
system that is a clear and present
danger to this Democratic Republic I'm
sure it's not a fun time for you and
your family this shouldn't have happened
in a lot of levels where's the collusion
there is none none all right Roger thank
you